this is really an awesome job for kids
when temperatures go up that means a
hiring frenzy we have seen this year
that it's been a bit of a challenge in
an already difficult hiring market shane
huge says cowabunga bay and canyon are
looking to get as many seasonal hires as
possible it's a challenge hiring 500
kids but now with both parks we will be
hiring over 1 000 seasonal employees
they'll be hiring teenagers for many of
the jobs that makes us the biggest
employer of youth so that's a lot of
teams to corral city pools also need
help saturday henderson will host a
hiring event at the whitney ranch
recreation center they are hiring
part-time positions for summer camps and
pools this is also open for those 16 and
older hiring is happening all over the
valley even right here on the strip the
tropicana pool opens on monday and they
are even offering an incentive to hire
more lifeguards for the season we're
actually offering an incentive bonus to
sign on with us and stay throughout the
season richard swabota is the director
of food and beverage at tropicana he
says the 2 000 signing bonus for
lifeguards is even for part-time jobs
anyone hired 16 and older this is the
first year that we've decided to do this
it's try to help get some more
candidates in he says the bonus will be
paid in installments throughout the
season they are competing with resorts
all over the strip they hope to get as
many lifeguards as possible post
pandemic times that we're in right now
it's been a little bit more challenging
but but we're hopeful that we're hopeful
we'll be able to get staffed up for the
season joe mohler live local now